c'est un sujet qu'on avait abordé
notamment au Sénat lors de la loi
climère résilience j'étais rapporteur et
nous avions à cette époque fait part au
gouvernement d'un certain nombre
d'inquiétudes quant à la mise en place
de ces ZFE qui sont importantes et
indispensables je dirais par rapport au
nombre de personnes qui sont victimes
quotidiennement de la pollution dans
notre pays pour autant par rapport à ces
impacts il faut pouvoir informer les
Français qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui il
faut pouvoir les accompagner notamment
avec différentes aides dans la
conversion de leur véhicule et puis
également redonner la main au territoire
parce que chaque territoire est
particulier bien sûr dans notre pays je
pense qu'il est indispensable d'associer
les élus locaux également dans toutes
les mesures de restriction qui sont
prises ce qui n'est pas rappelé c'est
que c'est pratiquement 40% des Français
qui en quelques années vont devoir
changer de véhicule vous imaginez les
conséquences que ça peut avoir puis il y
a la question du contrôle il n'y a rien
de pire que de mettre en place une
mesure et ensuite de faire que les
concitoyens de la respectent pas et ne
pas appliquer de contrôle donc il vous
paraît logique que les mesures qui
seront prises col avec un contrôle
effectif et aujourd'hui les contrôles ne
sont pas prêts donc pour toutes ces
régions nous avions déjà demandé un
report à l'époque qui n'avait pas été
accepté par le Gouvernement et on voit
aujourd'hui que par rapport à une
situation particulièrement tendue dans
les 45 agglomérations qui vont être
concernés prochainement dans les
métropoles qui le sont déjà il y a un
vrai besoin de d'information et puis de
revoir certaines mesures et de les
lisser dans le temps
[Musique]